norwegian cirrus johan galtung developed
a three-layered understanding of
violence that represents how a
confluence of factors merge in
particular historical moment to shape
the conditions for the promotion of
violence direct violence is what we
normally think of when we think about
violence it represents behaviors that
serve to threaten life itself and/or to
diminish one's capacity to meet basic
human needs such as killing maiming
bullying sexual assault and emotional
manipulation structural violence
represents the systematic ways in which
some groups are hindered from equal
access to opportunities to goods and
services that enable the fulfillment of
basic human needs these can be formal as
in legal structures that enforce
marginalization such as apartheid in
South Africa or they could be informal
but common practices such as limited
access to education or health care for
marginalised groups cultural violence
represents the existence of prevailing
or prominent social norms that make
direct and structural violence seem
natural or right or at least acceptable
for example the belief that Africans are
primitive and intellectually inferior to
Caucasians gave sanctions to the African
slave trade
galvan was understanding of cultural
violence helps explain how prominent
beliefs can become so embedded in a
given culture that they function as
absolute and inevitable and are
reproduced uncritically across
generations these three forms of
violence are interrelated and mutually
reinforcing and understanding them
better is crucial for the pursuit of a
broader and deeper
peace
[Music]